depuis un an la candidate à la mairie de
montréal valérie plantes parle d'une
cinquième ligne pour le métro de
montréal
la rose 22 km 29 stations 5 milliards
900 millions si on veut désengorger
notre no nos rues nos routes à montréal
il faut offrir des options pour projet
montréal puisqu'il y aura plus de monde
dans le métro il y aura moins de
congestion routière alors enlevé
[Musique]
ça semble peut-être logique tout seul
plus de monde dans le métro ça veut dire
moins de monde sur les routes
mais dans ce cas précis les études pour
prouver qu'une éventuelle ligne rose
diminuerait la congestion à montréal
elle n'existe tout simplement pas selon
les experts consultés on ne peut pas
dire maintenant que ça ferait diminuer
la congestion routière
parce qu'il faut d'abord évaluer combien
de gens vont utiliser la ligne
il faut aussi savoir si la ligne fait
économiser du temps pour la plupart des
utilisateurs
[Applaudissements]
je vous donne un exemple qu'on a vécu
ici quand on a construit les trois
stations du métro de laval en 2007
on s'attendait à ce qu'il y ait trois
mille voitures de moins par jour
mais le nombre de voitures a continué
d'augmenter dans les années qui ont
suivi
mais ce projet de ligne rose est ce
qu'il y fait faisable et à marc antoine
gautier qui nous a écrit c'est un
étudiant en urbanisme et dit que
plusieurs personnes autour de lui trouve
que c'est farfelu y en a d'ailleurs un
autre qui pensent à peu près la même
chose on nous l'aurons valeur et sg la
ligne bulle on ne montre pas de couleur
on sent trop pour nous l'une est rose la
faisabilité ça repose parfois sur peu de
choses d'abord faut savoir persuader
parce que dans ce genre de projet là la
ville de montréal est loin d'assumer la
facture tout seul la plupart du temps
fait c'est québec qui paie il faut
savoir convaincre aller chercher
l'argent ailleurs
et ça prend de la volonté politique dans
les années 70 en a fallu de la volonté
politique pour construire les 20
premières stations du métro de montréal
en quatre ans tout comme le réseau
électrique métro voltaire la caisse de
dépôt qui en théorie doit être prêt en
2020 si vous voulez qu'on vérifie
quelque chose
écrivez nous